Keith can you explain virtual production
workflow virtual production is a little
bit different than the normal film
making process and it starts what we
call previs um a client will come to us
and say Hey I want to do this project in
virtu production um so everything in R
production is done in that
pre-production process there's a lot of
planning so I one of the questions we
ask them is well what are you trying to
achieve and what are some different ways
we can achieve it because not
every not every Ro production shoot
requires what we call a 3D asset which
is using on engine and there's also
called 2D assets which we use as well
which is a video or image plates which
basically for people who don't know what
that is is basically a video file or
image file which's displayed on the LED
wall so um and that can kind of parallel
with in camera view effects which I can
get to get into later but um anyways so
if a person comes to us they're like hey
we want to do this we start talking
about okay what are we going to use 2D
asset 3D asset do we need camera
tracking with the 3D asset under engine
and depending on what they need we'll
make that determination um so we start
planning it out help them out with you
know decorating the foreground with
whatever practicals they need to sell
that environment like if they're in the
snow mountains um where to get a proper
set dresser person to come in and we
help facilitate that um so we talk about
all these different things and like talk
about the certain camera they're using
and the technical elements that you know
what's involved in Virtual production
not just in camera what you can see but
also with um The Blocking and placements
of the actor compared to the wall
depending on what shots they want so a
lot of that stuff discussed in the
previs in pre-production and we shoot in
Virtual production since everything's
with an LED walls a backdrop versus a
green screen it's all shot in what we
call picture so when you're in
postproduction you don't have to worry
about compositing and you know taking
that green screen out putting whatever
back background you want in there it's
all shot in the can so that's one of the
big benefits um so so yeah so so
everything's shot there it saves them a
amot of time so we talk about all these
elements and you know when it's time for
the shoot they come in we Tech advise
and help them out with all those
different things I just discuss and um
we decorate with the right foreground
dressing depending on the scene right
and we light it properly for the shots
they want and the proper lens um focal
length you know if they want like a
tighter shot on a 50 or 65 millimeter or
if they're trying to get a wide shot
which can be achieved well on for
production just there's more precise
blocking what has to be done we help
them out with that so that's a lot of
technical stuff that we help out with so
we get them what they want and then if
they're using the UN engine we'll if
they want camera tracking to create that
Parallax we help them out with that as
well so um if they're just using a 2d U
asset such as a video image plate um
then it doesn't have camera tracking on
it so uh just depends what they need so
that's kind of the whole the whole
process works with viral production and
then they then have that footage they
can take to go into post direction it's
all shot in picture so they don't have
to do any compositing um but all that
previous work is done up front for
pre-production where all those things I
just discussed have to be precisely
talked about so it's lit properly they
have the right you know focal length
millimeter 50 or 65 mm whereever it's a
tire shot or it's a wider shot whatever
they're trying to achieve so um so yeah
they take that in post production and
they have you know we give them
something good what they want for their
project so that's kind of the whole
process from virtual production how it
kind of works from being then but uh but
yeah I know I talked a lot about the 2DS
like a video image play but in camera
effects can kind of parallel with
virtual production so I can go into that
as well but we do
both and can someone use their own DSLR
camera
um yes and no so I tell people um I have
a guide I give out to people um for
cinematographers who come in um I
recommend strongly a cinema camera a
film camera when you come into a virtual
studio um where has shutter angle and
different things on it for settings um
dslrs I don't recommend for various
reasons there's very few settings we
work on a
DSLR um not if at all depends on the
camera on the DSLR but there's very few
settings will work on DSR camera so
myself my team we don't recommend those
uh bring cinema camera into our studio
or I'd recommend that to any virtual
studio so yeah and and I'm assuming no
no
iPhones yeah so also so now good
question now phones also like phone
cameras you're going to have a lot of
issues with as well um in these issues
I'm talking about you'll see we call
banding U horizontal banding and
flickering um there's different terms in
the in ret production in the VFX
Community for this some people call like
line tearing um and flickering
horizontal Banning but you're going to
see different elements um and you're
going to see a lot of that with a phone
camera you can't get around it unless
you can adjust some certain settings um
what need to be done especially with a
cinema camera what that can offer so
what phones don't offer so yeah you're
going to see issues with the phone
camera can you explain what is Parallax
sure so parallx so basically okay so in
ver production we have our 3D asset
which is under engine right um if you
have under engine and you're going to
have a um a camera tracker what gets
mounted on the top of the camera and
depending on the type of um camera
tracking solution you're using you're
going to have it depends like if you're
using Moses you're going to have these
little star these little reflectors on
the ceiling there's different there's
different companies would offer
different things or they might have like
a base stations these there's another
camera tracking solution has they call
them base stations and it receives a
signal they all operate this similar
they receive a signal to the camera
tracker and that camera tracker gets
tied in unison with a in-game camera so
there's an actual camera inside on their
engine we call a c camera actor and
that's through a um a plugin in on
engine ties both of those in unison so
the camera tracker and the in-game
camera so when it's tied together
basically when you move your camera
tracker on top of the camera it's the
screen we call parall in it's um it's
shifting it's it's moving it's it's
changing perspective so if you're
panning left or right it's the
environment is going to pan left or
right so if your actor or your subject
in front is moving left or right when
the camera tracker when the camera is
moving left or right it's going to move
with it so it creates that real 3d
effect that you're actually there um
versus a static image so that is the
definition of Parallax and kind of how
it works what it is and uh what's
involved what is realtime rendering sure
uh real-time rendering is basically
creating assets on the fly so like if
you're going to create a 3D assets an
non engine what we call it um uh you're
creating it on the spot so you are
either creating that environment on the
spot or you're moving objects uh in the
background and under engine on the spot
so everything's done when we call in
real time which means immediately so if
you want to change like mountain ridges
if you want to change waterfalls in this
background or um like buildings anything
you can move them around you can delete
them you can change the sunlight
Direction you keep it in the sunlight in
a certain area at all times um but it
can be changed in like I said what we
call real time immediately so you can
change things in real time and you can
um you can create the environment on the
spot if you want me'll take some time
like if you're usually an asset like a
3D asset on engine it's going to be
created way in advance um but you can
move things out in and out in the game
program immediately so in real time um
so that's one of the big benefits but
that's generally what it is so you have
that that computer gaming Software
System what's you're changing things
you're creating things on the spot so
that's why it's so beneficial real-time
rendering um you're creating things on
the Fly for what you want for the
production they're like hey I don't want
that Mountain Ridge there I want to have
this there I want that building moved
over here you just change it right there
in a split second and that's it what
about in post production m can you do
the same or no once you've shot the
image it's there to stay well there's a
lot of things you can do in post-
production now so I mean I would say yes
it depends on who who your VFX guy is in
post-production I mean you can do a lot
of stuff but
um I mean the whole purpose of virtual
production and rear projection with Le
walls is it's all shot in the can it's
all shot in picture so you don't have to
do that you don't have to do a lot of
work in post- production but I mean if
you're hire the right person and you're
like hey I don't I changed I don't like
that mountain ridge in the background I
mean I'm sure they can work some magic
to get it out I've never done that I I
mean I don't we don't we don't really do
that for the post- production work we
just deal with the virtual production
aspect um but uh but yeah how do you
match the lighting especially with
people in front of the screen and then
what's on the screen sure yeah so the
lighting that's one of the biggest
elements would help sell vir production
and you have to be very careful on how
you light um most cinematographers you
know we guide them when they come here
and they'll figure it out but we we Tech
VI and all that so you're going to match
your lighting sources so if you have
like say you're like in an Alleyway or
something in a three environment or
under engine or whatever even the video
image plates um you're going to match
your lighting Source if you have like a
street light coming from like over here
you're going to match that and say it's
like a neon light well you're going to
put a neon light over here and try to
match as best as possible so you really
just try to it's not too technical I
mean it seems it but you just match
what's on the LED wall wherever your
lagging is coming from sunlight or
wherever you put that sun that that
Lighting in the same area to come down
on your subjects um so that's how you
kind of light it so there's different
elements and wherever else is needed to
sell you know that you're in
environments can you tell us about using
virtual production to take advantage of
golden hour well I can remember as
myself going on locations uh and filming
and having to worry about rushing to get
that shot off because of you know the
sun's running out you're running out
time you want that specific look with
the sun in a certain direction you know
for your environment um but with this
Inver production is you don't have to
worry about that at all because the sun
can now be manipulated to stay in the
same exact direction for the whole time
you're there essentially or it can be
moved it can be taken out you can make
it nighttime um but you can make it that
golden AR the whole time the whole 12
hour day if you want for how many scenes
you want so that's one of the big
benefits of having it versus is like hey
I only have 30 minutes to get the shot
now you have 12 hours or however long
you're in the studio how does virtual
production impact travel
costs yeah that's um well huge because
now with the virtual Studio everything's
shot in the studio you don't have to
travel anywhere you just go to the
studio and the cast and crew doesn't
have to travel 2 hours to get to the
mountains or deserts or wherever the
location is if you want to shoot an
indoor location a mountain ridge
location like a desert location one day
you can do that so you just go to the
virtual studio and everything can
literally be changed on that LD wall in
a matter of seconds if you're using on
engine or even a video image plate
changed in a second so so yeah you don't
have to travel two hours to get to these
locations you can do everything right
there and that's where it cuts down on
your production time literally in half
so instead of a 12-day shoot you're
doing a six- day shoot because now you
just did a a shot on the skyscraper of
New York your next scene is um indoors
somewhere and then now you're out
mountain in the mountains the snowy
mountains doing some snow scene it's all
shot right there wherever the studio is
at and what about the fact that as
filmmakers start using this technology
that maybe a lot of films will have the
same uh
backgrounds well you know well yes and
no I mean I mean they can I mean so
under engine you can make you can make
these backgrounds um so whoever either
yourself or whoever your team is either
your team makes it or you can Source
through another contractor who makes
under engine
backgrounds um so yeah either you make
it yourself or another contractor
whoever there's different ways there's a
Marketplace you can get them as well so
um royaltyfree commercial free so yeah
so there's constantly new new
environments being made or like I said
you make yourself and if you're using a
2d asset such as a video image plate you
can go film those yourself shoot them
yourself or you can go online too and
get royaltyfree stock free um images or
video files to to use so there's there's
tons of ways to keep getting the files
and making them so yeah so the
possibilities are endless that you're
not going to be sort of like there's not
going to be a hundred templates and
everyone's going to have the same thing
right because essentially with Onre
engine I mean they're always making
there's so many different assets and
things where constantly being made that
you can get for yourself or make it
yourself um you can constantly it's
endless possibilities and same with
video image plates you can go and shoot
those yourself or get it from somebody
else so yeah there's no like I'm I'm not
worried about it I know a lot of other
filmmakers they shouldn't be worried
about like seeing the same backdrop for
like different movies and stuff cuz
anything can be made it doesn't matter
what it is you just design it from
scratch